Researchers who study eating disorders sometimes call them the silent epidemic. Estimates vary, but as many as 30 million Americans may suffer from an eating disorder at some point in their lifetime. And despite the stereotype that eating disorders afflict only young white women, the truth is that they can occur among people of all ages, genders, ethnicities, and races. Psychologists are working to learn more about the causes of eating disorders and how to treat them. Researchers are using new tools and technologies to come up with more effective, personalized treatments and expand access to care. So how common are eating disorders among adults, teens, and children?
研究饮食失调症的学者有时将其称为“沉默的流行病”。虽然估算数据各不相同，但多达3000万美国人在其一生中的某个阶段可能患有饮食失调症。尽管人们普遍认为饮食失调症只困扰年轻白人女性，但事实是，它可能发生在任何年龄、性别、族裔和种族的人群中。心理学家们正致力于深入了解饮食失调症的成因及其治疗方法。研究人员正在利用新的工具和技术来制定更有效、更个性化的治疗方案，并扩大医疗服务的覆盖范围。那么，饮食失调症在成人、青少年和儿童中的普遍程度如何呢？
What do researchers know about the causes of eating disorders, both genetic and environmental? What role does our diet-obsessed culture play in spurring eating disorders? What treatments are available now and how effective are they? barriers to treatment to patients face and how my technology help make treatments more available and effective. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Sherry Levinson, an associate professor in the Department of Psychological and Brain Sciences at the University of Louisville, where she directs the Eating Anxiety Treatment Lab.
研究人员对饮食失调症的遗传和环境成因有哪些了解？我们这种痴迷于节食的文化在诱发饮食失调症方面扮演了什么角色？目前有哪些治疗方法，效果如何？患者在治疗过程中面临哪些障碍，技术又如何帮助提高治疗的可及性和有效性？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。今天的嘉宾是路易斯维尔大学心理与脑科学系副教授谢丽·莱文森博士，她在那里负责饮食焦虑治疗实验室。
Her research focuses on building new interventions for eating disorders, particularly using analytical methods and new technologies such as wearable sensors as part of personalized treatments. Dr. Levinson is also the founder and clinical director of the Louisville Center for Eating Disorders, where she treats adults, adolescents, and children with eating disorders. She is also vice chair of the Kentucky Eating Disorder Council, a state-sponsored council charged with improving eating disorder treatment in Kentucky. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Levinson. Thanks for having me. I'm really excited to be here and get to talk about this really important topic. Yeah, me too. So I mentioned in the introduction that you and other researchers have called eating disorders a silent epidemic.
她的研究重点是构建针对饮食失调症的新干预措施，特别是利用分析方法和可穿戴传感器等新技术作为个性化治疗的一部分。莱文森博士还是路易斯维尔饮食失调中心的创始人和临床主任，她在那里治疗患有饮食失调症的成人、青少年和儿童。她同时担任肯塔基州饮食失调委员会的副主席，这是一个由州政府资助的委员会，负责改善肯塔基州的饮食失调治疗工作。感谢您今天参加节目，莱文森博士。谢谢邀请。我很高兴能来到这里，并讨论这个非常重要的话题。是的，我也是。我在介绍中提到，您和其他研究人员将饮食失调症称为“沉默的流行病”。
Has this always been true or is the prevalence of eating disorders on the increase? I would say it has always been true and the epidemic is getting larger and more problematic. hospitalizations and children and adolescents have doubled in the past year, and the prevalence rate for eating disorders is unfortunately rapidly growing. Now, I would guess that most of our listeners have heard of disorders like anorexia or nervosa or bulimia, binge eating disorders, things like that. Are there other diagnoses, other eating disorders that people might be less familiar with? Yeah, definitely. So as you mentioned, anorexia nervosa and bulimia nervosa are the eating disorders we usually hear about. But there are many additional eating disorders. So, for example, binge eating disorder is a newer, recognized eating disorder. It's similar to bulimia nervosa, except in that there is, you're eating a large amount of food and feeling out of control when you're eating it. But there's no compensating.
这种情况一直存在吗？还是说饮食失调症的患病率正在上升？我想说它一直存在，而且这种流行病正在变得越来越大、越来越严重。过去一年中，儿童和青少年的住院人数翻了一番，不幸的是，饮食失调症的患病率正在迅速增长。我想大多数听众都听说过厌食症、贪食症、暴食症之类的疾病。还有其他人们可能不太熟悉的诊断或饮食失调症吗？是的，当然。正如您所提到的，神经性厌食症和神经性贪食症是我们通常听到的饮食失调症。但还有许多其他的饮食失调症。例如，暴食症是一种较新的、被认可的饮食失调症。它类似于神经性贪食症，不同之处在于，你会摄入大量食物，并且在进食时感到失控。但没有补偿行为。
impensatory behaviors like purging or excessive exercise afterwards. And then actually, the most common eating disorder is what's called other specified feeding and eating disorder. And this is just a catch-all category for any other type of problematic eating that is causing impairment and distress in the person's life. And other specified feeding or eating disorder are osfed for short. That's a mouthful, right? is actually 50% of all people with an eating disorder would have OSFED.
比如事后催吐或过度运动等补偿行为。事实上，最常见的饮食失调症被称为“其他特定的进食或饮食失调症”（OSFED）。这只是一个包罗万象的类别，涵盖了任何其他类型的、导致个人生活受损和痛苦的问题性进食行为。其他特定的进食或饮食失调症，简称OSFED。这名字挺拗口的，对吧？实际上，50%的饮食失调患者都属于OSFED。
And this includes things like a typical anorexia nervosa, which is just the same as anorexia nervosa, except it occurs at all weights. You don't have to be underweight. And this is a very, very common and impairing eating disorder. And I also mentioned in my introduction the misconception that eating disorders mostly affect young white women. What are some of the other myths around eating disorders? Yeah, so I think that's a big one. There's a lot of stereotypes that it's young white women, but in fact, we know that eating disorders impact men, they impact children, they impact older adults, they impact minority
这包括非典型神经性厌食症等情况，它与神经性厌食症相同，只是发生在各种体重的人群中。你不必体重过轻。这是一种非常非常普遍且具有破坏性的饮食失调症。我在介绍中还提到了一个误区，即饮食失调症主要影响年轻白人女性。关于饮食失调症还有哪些其他误区？是的，我认为这是一个很大的误区。有很多刻板印象认为患者都是年轻白人女性，但事实上，我们知道饮食失调症会影响男性、儿童、老年人以及少数族裔。
individuals. There's lots of other myths around eating disorders as well. I think one is that people cause eating disorders or that it's just a phase. But we actually know that eating disorders are a highly genetically heritable illness, the same way that cancer or diabetes is heritable. And then the trigger for many eating disorders are societal factors, but they are biological illnesses and they are in a phase. People don't grow out of them. You really need expert treatment.
个人。关于饮食失调症还有许多其他误区。我认为其中之一是认为人们自己导致了饮食失调，或者这只是一个阶段。但我们实际上知道，饮食失调症是一种高度遗传的疾病，就像癌症或糖尿病一样具有遗传性。许多饮食失调症的诱因是社会因素，但它们是生物性疾病，而不是一个阶段。人们不会随着年龄增长而自然康复。你确实需要专业的治疗。
and lots of support to get better from an eating disorder. So you mentioned the genetic component. If someone has that predisposition to having an eating disorder, what's the kind of trigger that might put them into a full-blown phase? So two of the biggest triggers for an eating disorder are any type of restriction and critical comments about weight, shape, or body. So I can talk a little bit more about both of those. For restriction, this would be any sort of energy, food energy deficit.
以及大量的支持才能从饮食失调症中恢复。您提到了遗传因素。如果某人有患饮食失调症的倾向，什么样的诱因可能会让他们进入全面发作的状态？饮食失调症的两个最大诱因是任何形式的节食和对体重、体型或身体的批评性评论。我可以详细谈谈这两点。对于节食，这指的是任何形式的能量或食物能量赤字。
So this might look like going on a diet. It might look like, oh, I'm having my tonsils out, and so I can't eat for 48 hours, and that might set off the eating disorder. But I think what's really important to think about with this is that we live in a culture that really promotes restriction and dieting behaviors. And so anybody that has this genetic vulnerability is pretty much guaranteed to at some point in their life go on a diet or go on a fast. And that can really be what triggers the eating disorder. The second really big risk factor are these critical comments on weight, shape, and body.
这可能表现为开始节食。也可能是，“哦，我要去切除扁桃体，所以48小时不能吃东西”，这可能会引发饮食失调症。但我认为，关于这一点，非常重要的一点是，我们生活在一个极力推崇节食和限制饮食行为的文化中。因此，任何有这种遗传脆弱性的人，几乎注定在生命中的某个时刻会去节食或禁食。这确实可能成为引发饮食失调症的导火索。第二个非常大的风险因素是这些对体重、体型和身体的批评性评论。
And again, our society, unfortunately, is really ripe with these sorts of comments and judgments, especially for folks who live. in larger bodies, which we know, for example. And another one of those myths is that eating disorders only impact people who are thin. But actually, most eating disorders are in people who are in mid-size or larger bodies. And any sort of critical comment, whether that's from a pediatrician or a primary care doctor or a parent, that can be something that causes people to change how they're eating. Again, spurring that restriction, and that will trigger an eating disorder. Is there a particular age or time in life when eating disorders most commonly start?
同样，不幸的是，我们的社会充斥着这类评论和评判，特别是针对那些生活在较大体型身体中的人，我们对此很了解。另一个误区是饮食失调症只影响瘦人。但实际上，大多数饮食失调症患者的体型是中等或较大的。任何形式的批评性评论，无论是来自儿科医生、初级保健医生还是父母，都可能导致人们改变进食方式。这再次引发了节食，从而诱发饮食失调症。饮食失调症通常在什么年龄或人生阶段开始？
Yeah. So we used to think that the age of onset for most eating disorders was between 13 to 15, so in adolescence. But actually, what we're seeing now is a younger and younger kids. So we're seeing between 9 to 11 years old. is when many eating disorders are beginning. Of course, an eating disorder can occur at any time point during the lifespan, but we do see most of them that really start between the ages of 9 and 13. And unfortunately, like I said, we are seeing more younger and younger kids who are getting eating disorders.
是的。我们过去认为大多数饮食失调症的发病年龄在13到15岁之间，即青春期。但实际上，我们现在看到的是越来越小的孩子。我们看到许多饮食失调症在9到11岁之间就开始了。当然，饮食失调症可能在生命周期的任何时间点发生，但我们确实看到大多数病例是在9到13岁之间开始的。不幸的是，正如我所说，我们看到越来越多的年幼儿童患上饮食失调症。
And if I'm a parent, what should I look for to know that my child may be developing and eating? disorder and it's not just a phase, as you said. There's a lot of things that parents can look for. So the number one most important thing is any sort of changes in eating habits. This is why we know that family meals can be so protective against eating disorders because parents are there to observe and notice if kids are starting to eat differently. So if all of a sudden your kid isn't finishing their food or all they want to start cutting out a food group. Maybe they decide to be vegetarian or vegan, but it's not really
如果我是家长，我应该注意什么，以了解我的孩子可能正在发展成饮食失调症，而不是像您所说的“只是一个阶段”？家长可以观察很多迹象。最重要的一点是饮食习惯的任何变化。这就是为什么我们知道家庭聚餐可以有效预防饮食失调症，因为父母可以在场观察并注意到孩子是否开始以不同的方式进食。如果你的孩子突然不吃完食物，或者他们想开始剔除某种食物类别。也许他们决定成为素食主义者或纯素食主义者，但并不清楚他们为什么要剔除这些食物的原因。你可能会注意到他们开始把食物带到卧室，或者他们开始在盘子里拨弄食物而不吃完。其他需要注意的迹象是孤立。如果你的孩子开始不再参加他们过去常做的活动。也许他们回到房间而不是和家人待在一起。你可能还会注意到孩子开始穿宽松的衣服来试图隐藏自己的身体，或者他们可能开始感到非常不舒服，比如穿着泳衣去游泳。所有这些都是可能正在发展成饮食失调症的迹象。我真的强烈建议家长密切关注孩子吃的东西。我知道当孩子开始进入
clear what the reasoning is for why they want to cut those foods out. You might notice that they're starting to take food to their bedrooms, or maybe they are starting to push their food more around the plate and not finish it. Other things to look for are isolation. So if your kids starting to not do activities that they used to do. Maybe they're going to their room instead of hanging out with the family. You might also notice kids starting to wear baggy or clothes to try to hide their body, or they might start to feel really uncomfortable, maybe going to the pool in a bathing suit. All of these things are signs that there might be an eating disorder developing. And what I would really urge parents to do is to keep an eye on what your kid is eating. So I know that when kids start to go
青春期时，他们往往在饮食和食物准备等方面开始获得更多的独立性。但作为家长，密切关注并确保孩子摄入足够的营养非常重要，因为青春期也是孩子生长发育、大脑发育的时期。为了大脑发育和生长，他们必须从食物中获得足够的能量才能正常发育。那么，在生命周期的另一端呢？老年人，比如40多岁甚至60多岁的人，突然患上饮食失调症常见吗？是的，我们确实看到这种情况也经常发生。同样，我认为这是一个长期以来被低估的年龄段。所以我们看到中老年人群中有两类人。一类是确实从12或13岁起就患有饮食失调症的人。他们一直很擅长隐藏它。他们已经将其融入了自己的生活。但它仍然造成了巨大的损害和痛苦，并塑造了他们的生活方式。我们会看到很多人进来，他们已经患有
into adolescence, oftentimes they start to gain a lot more independence with what they're eating and food preparation and all of that sort of thing. But as a parent, it's really important to keep an eye and make sure that your kid is eating enough because the adolescence is also a time when kids are growing, when their brains are developing. And for, brain development and for growth, they have to be getting enough energy from food to properly develop. Now, what about on the other end of the lifespan? Is it common for somebody older, like in their 40s or even in their 60s, to suddenly develop an eating disorder? Yeah, we definitely see that happening a lot as well. Again, I think that this is a age group where really eating disorders
20、30年之久的饮食失调症，却从未得到治疗。另一类是新发饮食失调症，这可能由多种原因引起。我们看到很多病例发生在退休、更年期、生孩子前后。所有这些都可能成为饮食失调症的诱因，伴随着荷尔蒙的变化以及不同的期望和角色。所以我们确实看到这种情况出现在所有不同的年龄段。目前有哪些治疗方法，这些选择对人们的效果如何？
have been under-detected for a long time. So there's two groups of people in older adulthood or mid-adulthood that we see. And that's people who have really had an eating disorder since they were 12 or 13 years old. And they have been really good at hiding it. They've kind of worked it into their life. But it's still just causing so much impairment and distress and shaping the way that they're living their life. And we'll see lots of people coming in that have had,
是的。目前确实有治疗方法。我想说的是，如果你认为自己可能患有饮食失调症，或者你所爱的人患有饮食失调症，康复是有可能的。有很好的治疗方法。尽早发现饮食失调症是最重要的事情，因为发现得越早，完全康复的可能性就越大。
20, 30 year-long eating disorders that haven't been treated. The other group is we do see new onset eating disorders, and this can be brought on by a wide range of things. So we see a lot of it happening around retirement, around menopause, around giving birth to kids. All of these things can be triggers for eating disorders with changing in hormones and different sorts of expectations and roles. So we do see this kind of thing come up in all different age groups. And what are some of the treatments that are available right now and how well do these options
所以我们有几种不同类型的治疗方法。当我们谈论成人的门诊治疗时，我们最好的治疗方法是增强型认知行为疗法（CBT-E）。如果你有青少年患者，最好的治疗方法是所谓的家庭治疗（FBT）。然而，对许多人来说，门诊治疗是不够的，他们需要去更高水平的机构接受饮食失调治疗。这可能是强化门诊项目、部分住院项目，甚至是住院治疗，具体取决于饮食失调症的严重程度。在这些类型的中心，他们接受的是一种多学科团队治疗，称为饮食失调专业护理。这是更高水平护理的标准，涉及与心理学家或治疗师、营养师以及通常是医生和/或精神科医疗提供者的合作。
work for people? Yeah. So there are treatments out there. And what I want to say is that if you think you might have a eating disorder or somebody you love has an eating disorder, recovery is possible. are good treatments out there. Catching the eating disorder as early as possible is the most important thing to do because the earlier you catch the eating disorder, the higher likelihood of full recovery.
在反应率方面，当我们观察门诊治疗时，我们知道大约50%接受青少年家庭治疗或成人增强型认知行为疗法的人会好转。显然，50%并不理想，对吧？我们希望提高这个数字。接受专业护理的人群数据也类似。我们看到大约40%到50%的人好转。但我认为这里需要补充一点，这是指一轮治疗后的结果。例如，某人可能需要进行三到四次专业护理，然后他们才能达到康复标准。这会稍微提高康复率。所以我认为从中得出的结论是，可能需要多轮治疗。
So we have a couple different types of treatments. When we're talking about outpatient treatment for adults, our best treatment is cognitive behavior therapy enhanced. If you have an adolescent, the best treatment is what's called family-based treatment. For many people, though, outpatient is not enough, and people will need to go to a higher level of care for eating disorder treatment. So this might be an intensive outpatient program, a partial hospital program, or even residential treatment or inpatient, depending on the severity of the eating disorder. And in those types of centers, they're receiving a multidisciplinary-based team type of treatment that's called eating disorder specialty care. and that is really the standard of care for at higher levels of care and involves working with a psychologist or therapist, a dietitian, and usually either a physician and or a medical, psychiatric medical provider.
可能需要尝试不同类型的治疗来找出最适合的方案。我们需要在创造成功率高于50%的饮食失调新疗法方面做得更好。那么，像减肥手术这样的方法呢？我的意思是，对于一些人来说，比如暴食症患者，这是一种治疗方法，对吧？他们就是无法控制自己。这有效吗？这算是最后的防线吗？
So in terms of response rates, when we're looking at outpatient treatments, we know that about 50% of people who receive either family-based treatment for adolescents or cognitive behavior, behavior therapy enhanced for adults will get better. So obviously, 50% is not ideal, right? We want to get that number up there. The numbers are similar for people receiving specialty care. We see about 40 to 50% of people who get better. But I think one thing that's important to hedge here is that that's from one round of treatment. So it might be, for example, that somebody needs to go into specialty care three or four times, and then they hit that recovery mark. And that's going to push up recovery bits a little bit. So I think the takeaway from this is it might take multiple rounds of treatment.
减肥手术不是饮食失调症的治疗方法。我绝不会建议任何患有饮食失调症的人进行减肥手术。减肥手术在健康问题方面可能有所帮助，但大多数效果是短期的，当你查看长期数据时，
It might take trying different types of treatment to figure out what type of treatment works best. And we need to do better in terms of creating new treatments for eating disorders that have a higher than 50% success rate. Now, what about something like bariatric surgery? I mean, that's a treatment for some people, right, who are just maybe binge eaters. I mean, they just can't get control. Is that effective? And is that sort of like the last line of defense?
减肥手术的疗效实际上并没有我们希望的那么高。减肥手术也是饮食失调症的诱因之一。哦。它可以诱发饮食失调症，或者它可以
So bariatric surgery is not a treatment for an eating disorder. And I would never recommend anybody with an eating disorder gets bariatric surgery. um bariatric bariatric surgery can be helpful in terms of health issues um but most of the effects are short term and when you look at longer term data
重新引发可能处于康复期的饮食失调症。事实上，我们知道，例如对于暴食症，最有帮助的事情之一是规律进食和摄入多种多样的食物。当我提到规律进食时，我的意思是每天吃三顿正餐和两到三次零食，大约每两到三小时吃一次，因为大多数暴食行为是由节食引发的。发生的情况是，某人整天吃得很少，到了晚上，他们饿极了，然后可能发生了什么压力事件，
bariatric surgery doesn't actually have um as high of efficacy as we would like it to bariatric surgery is also one of those triggers for eating disorders. Oh. Um, it can either trigger an eating disorder or it can
这就会引发暴食，对吧？所以如果我们开始规律进食并使饮食模式正常化，这实际上就开始减少并预防了许多暴食行为。再加上学习如何应对压力和情绪反应，这才是暴食症CBT治疗的核心。所以如果你想一想，减肥手术实际上极大地改变了你的进食方式，并限制了你可以吃的东西。因此，这实际上可能会引发更多的暴食。有没有任何药物疗法对神经性厌食症或暴食症有效？我也在想最近关于像Ozempic这样的药物的新闻报道，对吧？它们被
um, reset off an eating disorder that maybe was in recovery. So we actually know, for example, that for binge eating disorder, one of the things that helps the most is regular eating and eating a variety of foods. So when I say regular eating, what I mean is eating three meals a day and two to three snacks about every two to three hours because most binge eating is triggered from restriction. So what happens is somebody goes all day and they're not eating very much. the end of the day comes along and they're starving and then maybe something stressful happens
作为肥胖症的治疗方法开具处方。是的。目前几乎没有对饮食失调症有效的药物。同样，我们知道我们的行为疗法比药物治疗更好。药物对于治疗焦虑和抑郁等共病问题非常有帮助，但它们并不能真正治疗饮食失调症本身。至于Ozempic，这是另一种情况，表面上看起来，有点像减肥手术，似乎，哦，嘿，也许这对饮食失调症有帮助。
and that is what sets off a binge, right? So if we start regular eating and we normalize the eating patterns, that actually starts to decrease and prevent a lot of the binge eating. That coupled with learning how to deal with stress and emotional reactions is really what goes into CBT treatment for binge eating disorder. So if you think about it, bariatric surgery, surgery is actually very much changing the way in which you eat, and it's limiting what you can eat. And so that can actually trigger more of these binges. Is there any kind of drug therapy that works either for anorexia nervosa or for binge eating? And I'm also thinking about the news coverage lately of drugs like OZempic, right, that are being
但Ozempic本质上是在抑制你的饥饿感和饱腹感信号，让你在并没有真正吃饱时感到饱。而这，同样是那种可能导致人们更多暴食的事情。它还有一些非常可怕的副作用，非常非常可怕的副作用，无论是在服用期间还是停药后。我最近读了很多关于它的资料，我的专业意见是尽可能远离Ozempic。除非，你知道，你有它最初被研发出来的那些医疗状况……
prescribed as a treatment for obesity. Yeah. So there is minimal medications that work for eating disorders. So again, we know that our behavioral treatments are better than medication treatments. Medications can be very helpful for treating the co-occurring issues like anxiety and depression worry, but they don't actually treat the eating disorder. In terms of Ozembeck, this is another one where maybe on the surface, kind of like bariatric surgery, It seems like, oh, hey, maybe this could be helpful for an eating disorder.
或者你是糖尿病患者。为它研发的，对吧，如果你是糖尿病患者。但如果你是为了减肥而使用它，它最终会对你的身体造成弊大于利的影响。而且它很可能最终会导致体重增加。从长远来看，因为我们知道，大多数时候，当人们通过节食、药物或其他任何形式减肥时，这种体重减轻在一年后都无法维持，最终发生的是你的身体说，我不喜欢这样。我不应该处于这个
But Ozymbic is essentially what it's doing is it's dampening your hunger and fullness cues, and it's making you feel full when you're not really full. And that, again, is the same sort of thing that can set people up to binge more. It also has some pretty scary side effects, very, very scary side effects, both in terms of being on it and when you go off of it. I've been doing a lot of reading on it lately, and my professional opinion is to stay as far away from Ozymbic as possible. Unless, you know, you have one of these medical conditions that it was originally...
身体尺寸，你的新陈代谢就会启动，它会干扰你的代谢功能，你的身体最终会想要达到比你开始节食时更高的体重。这就是我们实际上知道大约98%的节食，即无监督的节食，会失败并实际上导致体重增加的原因。现在，你的大部分研究都集中在利用技术开发有效的个性化治疗方法上。你能谈谈这个吗？你正在使用什么样的技术，它们是如何工作的？
Or you're diabetic. Develop for it, right, if you're diabetic. But if you're losing it for weight loss purposes, it is going to end up doing more harm than good to your body. And it's probably actually going to end up leading to weight gain. the long term because we know that most of the time when people lose weight on diets or from medications or what other other sort of form they're using, that weight loss never sustains itself past a year and what ends up happening is your body says, I don't like this. I'm not supposed to be at this
是的，我们目前正在进行几项临床试验，其中包含一些非常令人兴奋的新疗法。所以我将简要谈谈其中的几个。我们正在进行的临床试验之一，我们使用智能手机，并使用一种人们每天多次在手机上评估其饮食失调症状以及焦虑和抑郁等情况的方法。我们利用这些数据创建一个算法，告诉我们这些是导致饮食失调症的症状，对于维持饮食失调症非常重要。然后我们将这些症状与循证治疗方法相匹配，以帮助解决该特定问题。通过这种方式，我们利用智能手机评估和复杂的算法（我就不深入探讨了）来实现治疗的个性化。但目前我们正在进行一项试验，测试个性化治疗与增强型认知行为疗法（目前被认为是护理标准）的对比。
body size and your metabolism kicks in and it messes with your metabolic features and your body ends up wanting to then be at a higher weight than it was when you even started the diet. And that's where we actually know that about 98% of diets, unsupervised diets, fail and actually lead to weight gain. Now, much of your research is centered on using technology to develop effective personalized treatments. Can you talk about that? What kind of technology are you using and how do they work?
我们还在使用可穿戴传感器来开发可以预测饮食失调行为发作的算法。我们的希望是最终能够利用它，比如在你的Apple Watch或Garmin中安装一些东西，可以发出警报，嘿，你可能准备要进行一次暴食了。让我们来练习这些技能。最后，我们正在开发虚拟现实和基于数字的化身疗法，以治疗诸如对体重增加的恐惧等症状，这是所有饮食失调症的主要症状。
Yeah, so we have a couple clinical trials that we are running right now with some really exciting new treatments. So I'll just briefly talk about a couple of them. So one of the clinical trials that we're running, we use smartphones and we use a type of people get assessments on their phones multiple times a day about their eating disorder symptoms and things like. anxiety and depression. And we use that to create an algorithm that tells us these are the symptoms that are causing the eating disorder that are really important for maintaining the eating disorder. And then we match that to evidence-based treatments to help with that specific problem. And so in that way, we're personalizing treatment using the smartphone assessment and fancy algorithms that I won't go into. But right now we're running a trial where we're testing personalized treatment versus cognitive
所以我们正在使用许多不同的技术。我们的希望是，我们可以利用这些技术来改善现有的治疗方法，同时也能够实现治疗的个性化，因为我们知道每个人的饮食失调症表现并不相同。我们希望人们能够真正获得对他们最有帮助的护理。说到技术，让我们谈谈社交媒体对饮食失调症的影响。我的意思是，我想我们都知道有一些网站，特别是年轻人会访问的关于暴食、催吐以及其他他们可以做的、不健康的事情的网站。我想知道，这是否导致了今天饮食失调症患者人数的增加？让我们谈谈
behavior therapy enhanced that type of treatment that right now is considered the standard of care. We're also using wearable sensors to develop algorithms that can predict onset of eating disorder behaviors. And our hope is to eventually be able to use that to Like have something in your Apple Watch, for example, or your Garmin, that can alert, hey, you might be getting ready to have a binge eating episode. Let's work on these skills. And then finally, we're developing things like virtual reality and digitally based avatar treatments to treat things like fear of weight gain, which is a major symptom in all eating disorders.
这一点。是的，当然。我绝对认为社交媒体可能是导致饮食失调和饮食失调症的一个因素。我认为澳大利亚有一些数据开始研究社交媒体与饮食失调、特别是身体不满之间的因果关系。我认为我们在社交媒体方面需要记住的是，它既可以是积极的，也可以是消极的，对吧？我们知道，实际上对儿童和青少年进行教育，教他们如何调整自己的社交媒体，使其成为一个更具支持性和身体中立的平台，可以完全改变
So we're using a lot of different technologies. And really our hope is that we can take this technology and use it to improve treatments that exist, but also to be able to personalize treatment because we know that everybody's eating disorder doesn't look the same. And we want people to really be able to get the care that is going to be most helpful for them. Well, speaking of technology, let's talk about the impact of social media on eating disorders. I mean, I think we all know that there are websites, particularly that young people will go to about binging, purging, other things that they can be doing that would not be healthy. And I'm wondering, is that contributing to the growing numbers of people with eating disorders today? Let's talk about
他们互动的方式，对吧？所以，如果有人在社交媒体上看到所有这些减肥广告，看到非常瘦的人，看到所有这些人对外观施加压力，这可能会导致比较，导致饮食失调。但你也可以以一种促进身体中立和身体功能的方式使用社交媒体。为什么我们的身体很棒，对吧？所以我认为，如果我们能进行更多的教育，并更个性化地了解如何最好地使用社交媒体，我们最终可以利用社交媒体来提供帮助，而不是造成伤害。那太好了。是的，绝对。
that a little bit if you could. Yeah, sure. I definitely think that social media can be a contributor to disordered eating and eating disorders. There's a little bit of data, I think actually out of Australia that's beginning to look at some of the causal relationships between social media and disordered eating, body dissatisfaction in particular. I think what we need to keep in mind with social media is that it can be a positive or it can be a negative, right? And we know that actually providing education to kids and adolescents on how to tailor their social media to make it a more supportive and body neutral platform can completely change
体育运动的作用是什么？我知道我们都见过这些体重只有100磅左右的女性体操运动员，或者也许你去健身房，那里有个家伙每天花几个小时试图练出超级强壮的肌肉。我的意思是，教练和体育界的其他人如何把握那条界线，在不通过节食、补充剂和其他不健康方案损害运动员身体的情况下，帮助他们发挥出最佳水平？是的。是的，这是一个很好的问题。而且非常重要。同样，我认为如果我们回顾一下我们在开头讨论的关于环境的内容，当
the way that they're interacting, right? So if you have somebody who's going on social media and they're seeing all of these weight loss ads and they're seeing very thin people and they're seeing all these people putting pressure on appearance, that can lead to comparisons, can lead to disordered eating. But you can also use social media in a way to promote body neutrality and the function of the body. Why our bodies are amazing, right? And so I think that if we can get more education and more personalization of how to best. use social media, we could end up helping instead of harming from social media. That would be great. Yes, definitely.
涉及到任何形式的节食、任何形式的批评性评论时，这可能会诱发饮食失调症，许多体育运动对体重、体型都有很多关注。可能会有关于体重和体型的评论。甚至可能在不同的体育项目中融入了节食。比如如果你想到摔跤手必须达到一定的体重限制，这确实是他们运动中固有的。所以我总是告诉教练和体育界的人，与其关注卡路里、体重减轻、你的身体看起来如何，你真正应该关注的是你身体的功能。所以你的身体很强壮。你可以跑得很快、很远。
What about the role of sports? I know we've all seen these female gymnasts who weigh about 100 pounds, or maybe you go to the gym and there's some guy who's there every day for hours on end trying to get super ripped. I mean, how can coaches and others in the world of sports walk that line between helping athletes become their best without damaging their bodies with diets, supplements, and other unhealthy regimens? Yes. Yes, this is a great question. And so important. And again, I think if we want to think back to what we talked about at the beginning about how the environment, when it
你可以用力击球。你需要食物来为这些提供能量，对吧？我们的能量从哪里来？我总是问我的病人这个问题，他们对我翻白眼。但我们的能量从哪里来？我们从吃的食物中获得，对吧？所以如果你想成为一名高水平的运动员，你必须有能量来为你的身体提供动力。而且你必须有足够的能量来感受你的身体。
comes to any sort of dieting, any sort of critical comments, that can spur eating disorders, a lot of athletics have a lot of focus on weight, on shape. There might be. comments about weight in shape. There might be even dieting that is worked into different sort of sports programs. Like if you think about wrestlers having to meet a certain weight cutoff, that is really inherent in their sport. So what I always tell coaches and people in athletics is that instead of focusing on calories, on weight loss, on how your body looks, what you really want to focus on is the function of your body. So your body is strong. You can and run really fast and really far.
如果你没有得到适当的营养，你的表现就不会好。所以我认为教练们可以更多地谈论为我们的身体提供适当的营养，这意味着规律进食、摄入多种多样的食物，以及我们身体为我们所做的所有惊人的功能。通过这种方式，我们可以创造一个更安全的环境，让饮食失调症无法滋生。焦虑和饮食失调症之间的关系是什么？为什么它们经常交织在一起？是的。
You can hit the ball hard. And you need food to fuel that, right? Where do we get our energy from? I ask my patients this all the time, and they roll their eyes at me. But where do we get our energy from? We get it from the food that we eat, right? So if you want to be a high-performing athlete, you have to have energy to fuel your body. And you have to have enough energy to feel your body.
我们的大部分研究都集中在焦虑和饮食失调症之间的重叠上。我们知道饮食失调症与焦虑症同时发生的概率高达95%。所以了解这一点非常重要，如果某人接受饮食失调症治疗，或者他们患有饮食失调症，他们不仅仅患有饮食失调症。他们还会患有焦虑症、抑郁症，你知道，其他共病情况，如物质使用和人格障碍。但饮食失调症确实是基于恐惧的疾病，对吧？就像焦虑症是基于恐惧的疾病一样。饮食失调症围绕着不同类型的恐惧，也许不像你可能
You are not going to perform well if you're not properly fueled. So that's what I think coaches can talk more about is properly fueling our body, which means eating regularly, eating a wide variety of foods, and all of the amazing functions that our body does for us. And in that way, we can create a safer environment where eating disorders are not going to thrive. What is the relationship between anxiety and eating disorders? Why are they so often intertwined? Yep.
在惊恐障碍或社交焦虑障碍中想到的那样。在饮食失调症中，恐惧和焦虑确实集中在对体重增加的恐惧上。如果我体重增加这么多会发生什么？人们会评判我吗？我会被抛弃吗？对食物的恐惧，所以想要避免某些食物。对社会评判的恐惧，人们会批判性地评判我的身体。还有对你身体感觉的恐惧。所以这可能是对身体感觉的误解。
So a lot of our research is focused on the overlap between anxiety and eating disorders. And we know that eating disorders co-occur with anxiety disorders up to 95% of the time. So this is really important to know that if somebody goes into treatment for an eating disorder or if they are living with an eating disorder, they don't just have an eating disorder. They're also going to have an anxiety disorder, depression, you know, other things co-occur like, substance use and personality disorders. But eating disorders are really fear-based disorders, right? In the same way that anxiety disorders are fear-based disorders. Eating disorders are centered around different types of fears than maybe like you might
所以我感到饱了，这让我感到害怕，因为我认为我正在增加所有这些体重。所以饮食失调症的核心确实是基于焦虑的，这就是为什么我们看到饮食失调症伴随这么多焦虑，以及为什么我们的团队，我的实验室，正在致力于开发从焦虑症改编而来的治疗方法，以更符合基于焦虑的疾病的方式来治疗饮食失调症。我在这里总是喜欢说的一件事是，强迫症（OCD），它与饮食失调症高度重叠，曾经被认为是一种难治性疾病，在暴露与反应预防（ERP）疗法发展之前，被认为无法治疗，而ERP正是治疗强迫症和焦虑症的方法。这是一种基于焦虑的
think of in panic disorder, for example, or social anxiety disorder. And eating disorders, the fear and anxiety is really focused on fears of weight gain. So what's going to happen if I gain all this weight. are people going to judge me? Am I going to get abandoned? Fears of food, so wanting to avoid certain foods. Fears of social judgment, people are going to judge my body critically. And then also fears of how your body feels. So it can be things like misinterpretation of bodily sensations.
治疗。同样，我们在治疗饮食失调症方面遇到了很多困难，但当我们开始应用这些基于焦虑的治疗方法时，我们确实看到了症状和焦虑的巨大下降。这是一个非常非常有前景的研究和新治疗领域。让我们花一分钟谈谈谁更容易患上饮食失调症。我的意思是，有一种刻板印象认为患者是女性和女孩。饮食失调症在女性和女孩中比在男孩和男性中更常见吗？是的，它们在女性和女孩中更常见，这取决于我们谈论的疾病类型。如果我们谈论的是暴食症，实际上有50%的男性和50%的女性会患上
So I feel full, and that makes me feel afraid because I think I'm gaining all of this weight. So really at their core, eating disorders are anxiety-based, and that's why we see so much anxiety with eating disorders and why our team, my lab, is working on developing treatments that are adapted from anxiety disorders to the eating disorders to treat eating disorders more in line with anxiety-based disorders. One thing I always like to say here is that so obsessive compulsive disorder, which is highly overlapping with eating disorders, was thought of as a refractory illness, something that couldn't be treated until the development of exposure and response prevention treatment, which is how OCD and anxiety disorders are treated. It's an anxiety-based
暴食症。我认为我们还需要考虑的另一件事是，男性的患病率可能比我们想象的要高得多，因为我们用来检测饮食失调症的所有评估和工具都是为女性开发的。男性饮食失调症的表现可能看起来有点不同。我的意思是，它们确实看起来与女性不同。因此，许多关于男性患病率低的估计，实际上可能是因为我们只是没有好的方法来检测它，而且我们没有寻找正确的东西。所以，例如，对于男性饮食失调症，可能会有更多关于拥有更大肌肉和锻炼的担忧。
treatment. And similarly, we've had so much trouble treating eating disorders, but when we start to apply these anxiety-based treatments, we really see huge decreases in symptoms and anxiety. It's a very, very promising area of research and new treatment. Let's talk for a minute about who is more likely to get an eating disorder. I mean, there is the stereotype that it's women and girls. Are eating disorders more common among women and girls than among boys and men? Yeah, so they are more common among women and girls, depending on the type of disorder we're talking about. if we're talking about binge eating disorder, it's actually 50% men, 50% women who will develop
举重更多，而你在女性身上可能较少看到这种情况，但我们没有询问这些事情，所以我们大部分时间都错过了。所以，我的意思是，我认为总的结论是，是的，作为女性确实会带来更高的患饮食失调症的可能性，但男性也会患上饮食失调症，而且患病率比我们过去认为的要高得多。现在，你谈到了有毒的节食文化在促进美国饮食失调症方面所扮演的角色。与此同时，许多人，包括医生和公共卫生官员，都在谈论对抗肥胖流行病的必要性。我们如何平衡这两个相互竞争的议程，以一种不刺激
binge eating disorder. And I think another thing that we need to think about is that rates and men are probably a lot higher than we think because all of our assessments and tools that we use to detect eating disorders have been developed for women. And eating disorders in men may look a little bit different. I mean, they do look a little bit different than in women. And so a lot of the estimate of low prevalence in men is really possibly because we just don't have good ways to detect it and we aren't looking for the right things. So, for example, with a male eating disorder, there might be much more concern about having bigger muscles and working.
饮食失调的方式？是的，这非常非常重要。这是我经常思考、谈论和撰写的话题。我认为我们需要考虑的是，那些想要治疗肥胖流行病的人，他们真正关心的是有时与较大体型相关的潜在健康问题，对吧？但这里的关键结论是，相关性并不等于因果关系，对吧？不幸的是，长期以来，我们的卫生系统有一种错误的信念，即处于较大的体型自动意味着你不健康，而事实并非如此。你可以处于较大的体型，并且和处于小体型的人一样健康，甚至更健康。
lifting weights more, whereas you might see less of that with women, but we're not asking about those things, so we're missing it a lot of the time. So, I mean, I think the overall takeaway message is, yes, being a female does bring with it a higher likelihood of having an eating disorder, but men also get eating disorders and at much higher rates than we used to think. Now, you've talked about the role that a toxic diet culture plays in promoting, promoting eating disorders in the United States. And at the same time, a lot of people, including physicians and public health officials, are talking about the need to fight the obesity epidemic. How do we balance these two competing agendas in a way that doesn't spur
真正重要的是健康行为，对吧？所以当我提到健康行为时，我的意思是规律进食、摄入多种多样的食物、吃全谷物、快乐运动。还有我们甚至没有谈论的系统性问题，比如导致无法规律进食的粮食不安全，对吧？比如拥有人们可以真正活动身体的绿地。我认为这些才是需要努力改善健康的事情，而不是针对肥胖（加引号）的个体因素或个体治疗。
disordered eating? Yes, this is so, so important. Something I think about, talk about, and write about a lot. I think that what we need to think about is that people who are wanting to treat the obesity epidemic, what they're really concerned about are the underlying health problems that are sometimes correlated with being in a larger body, right? But the key takeaway here is that correlation does not equal causation, right? And unfortunately, for too long, our health system has the incorrect belief that being in a larger body automatically means that you're unhealthy, and that is just not the case. You can be in a larger body and be as healthy or more healthy than people who are in a small body.
所以我喜欢指出的一点是，整个肥胖流行病实际上并不存在，但美国人被灌输了这种东西存在，这实际上是出于想要确保我们的孩子安全，并且他们将来不会患上这些可怕的健康问题，对吧？所以我总是喜欢说的一个统计数据是，好吧，你知道，稍微退一步说，我们在这里思考的是，我们想要预防的儿童健康问题是什么。其中很多是像糖尿病这样的疾病，对吧？所以我喜欢给出的统计数据是，如果我们有10万名儿童和青少年，其中120人会患有唐氏综合症，
What's really important are the health behaviors, right? So when I say health behaviors, what I mean are things like eating regularly, eating a large variety of foods, eating whole grains, joyful movement. And then there's the systemic issues that we're not even talking about, things like food insecurity that prevent being able to regular eat, right? Things like having access to green space where people can actually move their bodies. These are the actual things that I think need to be worked on to help improve health, not individual factors or individual treatment of obesity, in quotes.
真正重要的是健康行为，对吧？当我提到健康行为时，我指的是像规律饮食、摄入多种多样的食物、吃全谷物、愉悦的运动等。此外还有我们甚至没有讨论的系统性问题，比如导致无法规律饮食的粮食不安全问题，对吧？比如是否有机会接触到人们可以真正活动身体的绿地。我认为这些才是真正需要去解决以改善健康的问题，而不是针对个人的因素或所谓的“肥胖症”的个体治疗。
So one thing that I like to point out is that the whole obesity, epidemic that really doesn't exist, but that Americans have been fed that this thing exists, was really brought out of wanting to make sure that our kids were safe and that they weren't developing these terrible health problems down the road, right? So one statistic that I always like to say is, well, you know, and so to back up a little bit, what we think about here is, well, what are the health problems that we're thinking about kids that we want to prevent. And a lot of it are things like diabetes, right? So the statistic that I like to give is that if we have 100,000 children in adolescence, 120 will have Down syndrome,
所以我喜欢指出的一点是，所谓的“肥胖流行病”其实并不存在，但美国人一直被灌输这种东西是存在的，这其实是出于想要确保我们的孩子安全，并且他们未来不会患上这些可怕的健康问题，对吧？所以我总是喜欢引用一个统计数据，嗯，你知道，稍微退一步说，我们在这里思考的是，我们想要预防孩子们的哪些健康问题。其中很多是像糖尿病之类的问题，对吧？所以我喜欢给出的统计数据是，如果我们有10万名儿童和青少年，其中120人会患有唐氏综合症，
56 will die from sudden infant death syndrome, 15 will be diagnosed from cancer, 12 will develop type 2 diabetes, and 2,900 will have an eating disorder. So, we'll be diagnosed. We'll have a eating disorder. So we're talking about 12 kids who are going to develop type 2 diabetes versus 2,900 that are going to have an eating disorder. And all of these sorts of things that people are doing to try to prevent, again, in quotes, the obesity epidemic, are things that cause eating disorders, asking people to restrict their food, making critical comments on their body and their weight and their shape. those things cause eating disorders. So unfortunately what we're seeing is that people well-intentioned, they're well-intentioned and they're trying to treat obesity, which really is not a problem in itself, and they're causing eating disorders. And that's part of why we're seeing these huge growth in eating disorders. So the estimate is in the next year there's going to be 2.9 million new cases of eating disorders in kids and adolescents.
56人将死于婴儿猝死综合征，15人将被诊断出患有癌症，12人将患上2型糖尿病，2900人将患上饮食失调症。所以，我们会被诊断出来。我们会患上饮食失调症。我们谈论的是12个孩子将患上2型糖尿病，而有2900人将患上饮食失调症。人们为了预防所谓的“肥胖流行病”而采取的所有这些措施，实际上正是导致饮食失调的原因，比如要求人们限制饮食，对他们的身体、体重和体型发表批评性评论。这些行为会导致饮食失调。不幸的是，我们看到的是，人们出于好意，他们确实是出于好意，试图治疗肥胖症，而肥胖本身并不是一个问题，但他们却导致了饮食失调。这就是为什么我们看到饮食失调症大幅增长的部分原因。据估计，明年将有290万名儿童和青少年出现新的饮食失调病例。
just in the next year. So I think that what we as a society need to start to grapple with is, number one, the size of your body does not equate to how healthy you are. And number two, we really need to think about our priorities. Are we so focused on obesity because of these inaccurate messages about what it means to be larger because of things like weight stigma? Is it really a problem? Maybe not. And maybe we need to be thinking more about the harm that we're causing with eating disorders instead of falsely trying to change people's body size, which we know doesn't work, right? Like, as I mentioned, 98% of diets fail. Your body size is actually 80% genetically based. That's about the same as eye color. You would never try and say, oh, I don't like your blue eyes. Let's try and change those to brown, right? So it's like, oh, oh, I don't like that you're in a large body that, you know, is genetically based. Let's try and make you smaller, right? And then we don't actually have a good way to make people smaller either.
仅仅是在明年。所以我认为，作为社会，我们需要开始面对的问题是：第一，你的体型大小并不等同于你的健康程度。第二，我们真的需要考虑我们的优先事项。我们是否因为关于大体型意味着什么的错误信息，以及体重歧视等问题，而过于关注肥胖？这真的是个问题吗？也许不是。也许我们需要更多地考虑饮食失调带来的危害，而不是错误地试图改变人们的体型，我们知道这根本行不通，对吧？正如我提到的，98%的节食都会失败。你的体型实际上80%是由基因决定的。这和眼睛的颜色差不多。你绝不会说，哦，我不喜欢你的蓝眼睛，让我们把它改成棕色，对吧？所以这就像是，哦，我不喜欢你拥有基因决定的这种大体型，让我们试着让你变小，对吧？而且我们实际上也没有什么好方法能让人变小。
Now, you've done advocacy work in your state to increase access to eating disorder treatment. What are the biggest barriers to patients when they're trying to access treatment? Is the problem, insurance, availability, or is it something else? Yeah. So we just did a large wide-scale study with Project Heal, which is a not-for-profit organization that tries to provide access to eating disorder treatment for people who are having difficulty with accessing treatment. And we surveyed 3,000 folks with an eating disorder who were treatment seeking, but maybe necessarily weren't able to get treatment. because we wanted to find out what are the barriers. I mean, I hear about the barriers all the time,
你曾在你所在的州进行过倡导工作，以增加人们获得饮食失调治疗的机会。患者在寻求治疗时面临的最大障碍是什么？问题在于保险、可及性，还是其他原因？是的。我们刚刚与Project Heal进行了一项大规模的研究，这是一个非营利组织，旨在为那些在获得治疗方面有困难的人提供饮食失调治疗机会。我们调查了3000名患有饮食失调症并寻求治疗但可能无法获得治疗的人，因为我们想找出其中的障碍。我的意思是，我一直听说这些障碍，
but we wanted to actually quantify what the barriers were. And we had five different barriers that categories that we were looking at. But overwhelmingly, the biggest barrier was financial. And by that, I mean insurance coverage. So insurance coverage for eating disorder treatment is very, very limited. especially if you have Medicaid or state-based non-commercial insurance, there are very few eating disorder treatment centers that take that because the reimbursement rates are so low.
但我们想真正量化这些障碍是什么。我们研究了五个不同的障碍类别。但压倒性的最大障碍是经济问题。我的意思是保险覆盖范围。饮食失调治疗的保险覆盖非常非常有限。特别是如果你有医疗补助（Medicaid）或基于州的非商业保险，很少有饮食失调治疗中心接受这些保险，因为报销率太低了。
So really, to be able to access treatment, you have to have commercial insurance or a lot of money, which unfortunately means only a small percentage of people, 20% of people with an eating disorder end up being able to access treatment. So definitely the biggest barrier is financial, is the way that our insurance system is set up. There's other barriers, though, too, like there aren't a large availability of providers, especially in rural areas and for minority populations. But again, that can be tied back to the fact that it's very hard to do that work if you're not going to be able to get coverage from an
所以，要获得治疗，你必须拥有商业保险或大量的资金，不幸的是，这意味着只有一小部分人，即20%的饮食失调患者最终能够获得治疗。所以最大的障碍绝对是经济问题，也就是我们保险系统的设置方式。当然还有其他障碍，比如医疗服务提供者并不多，特别是在农村地区和少数群体中。但同样，这可以追溯到这样一个事实：如果你无法从保险公司获得报销，那么从事这项工作是非常困难的。
insurance company to do it. Other things are just lower quality of care in certain areas, geographic barriers. So, for example, the clinic that I run is the only eating disorder center and the entire state of Kentucky. Most of our eating disorder treatment facilities are either on the west or the east coast or in Colorado. So many people have to travel four to, you know, 24 hours to get treatment. And many people don't have the resources to do that type of treatment, especially for three to six months, which is often how long folks are in a higher level of here. So it sounds like technology is really the answer for a lot of people, because that will be more readily available. Technology, I think, in continued advocacy for systemic change so that we can
其他问题包括某些地区的护理质量较低，以及地理障碍。例如，我经营的诊所是整个肯塔基州唯一的饮食失调中心。我们大多数饮食失调治疗设施要么在西海岸或东海岸，要么在科罗拉多州。所以许多人必须长途跋涉4到24小时才能获得治疗。许多人没有资源进行那种类型的治疗，特别是对于需要三到六个月的疗程，这通常是人们在更高级别护理中所需的时间。所以听起来技术确实是许多人的答案，因为那样会更容易获得。我认为，技术以及持续倡导系统性变革，以便我们能够
have better coverage. If you look at, for example, the mental health parity laws, and each of the states have a rating for how well they do mental health disparity from A to F. So, you know, everybody wants an A. Nobody wants an F. Well, I think it's something like 47 states get an F and like two states have a D minus and one has a D. So, so I, so I, so I, I mean, the point is, is that we're not doing well when it comes to mental health parity. And that's not just eating disorders, that everything. Yeah. Right.
获得更好的保险覆盖。如果你看看心理健康均等法，每个州对心理健康均等表现的评分从A到F不等。每个人都想要A，没人想要F。我认为大约有47个州得了F，两个州得了D减，一个州得了D。所以，我的意思是，重点在于，在心理健康均等方面我们做得并不好。这不仅仅是饮食失调，而是所有方面。是的。没错。
So I think that while technology is definitely an answer that I think is going to provide so much more access to more people, there also needs to be this advocacy and push to our legislators to take mental health seriously and to really change the systems so that everybody can access. high quality care. So last question, something practical, since we're talking about barriers, what should you do if you or someone you know has an eating disorder or you suspect that they might? What's the best way to get help? Yeah.
所以我认为，虽然技术绝对是一个答案，我认为它将为更多人提供更多的机会，但也需要这种倡导和推动，要求我们的立法者认真对待心理健康，并真正改变系统，以便每个人都能获得高质量的护理。最后一个问题，谈点实际的，既然我们在谈论障碍，如果你或你认识的人患有饮食失调症，或者你怀疑他们可能患有，你应该怎么做？获得帮助的最佳方式是什么？是的。
So what I would say is don't hesitate to get help. As I mentioned earlier, the sooner you intervene on an eating disorder, the more likely full recovery is possible. There's a lot of good resources out there that can get folks to good treatment. So I mentioned Project Heal. That's a great resource. The National Eating Disorder Association, or Nita, is another great one that has links to different treatment.
我会说，不要犹豫，寻求帮助。正如我之前提到的，你对饮食失调的干预越早，完全康复的可能性就越大。有很多好的资源可以帮助人们获得良好的治疗。我提到了Project Heal。那是一个很好的资源。国家饮食失调协会（NEDA）是另一个很好的资源，上面有不同治疗方法的链接。
They actually have a chat bot that one of my colleagues has developed that helps get you into treatment. So you don't even have to talk to a person. And you can always go to our website, which is, the Louisville EatLab.com and the Louisville Center for Eating Disorders. We have resources on there for how to get treatment. Nita is great for how do you, they have resources on how do you talk to somebody with an eating disorder. You can also reach out to your local psychology organization.
他们实际上有一个聊天机器人，是我的一位同事开发的，可以帮助你进入治疗流程。所以你甚至不需要和人交谈。你也可以随时访问我们的网站，即LouisvilleEatLab.com和路易斯维尔饮食失调中心。我们在上面有关于如何获得治疗的资源。NEDA在如何与饮食失调患者交谈方面做得很好，他们有相关资源。你也可以联系你当地的心理学组织。
So for example, in Kentucky, we have the Kentucky Psychological Association. All states have a similar sort of association that you can reach out to. And all of these resources are out there to help get people into the care they need. And what I'll stress again is just that you really do need people with specialty training to treat the eating disorders. You want to be looking for evidence-based care so that people don't end up bouncing from one place to the next, not getting the type of treatment that's going to be helpful. and just how important it is to reach out for help and not to be ashamed of having an eating disorder. Like I said, you would never be ashamed of having cancer or some other type of illness, right?
例如，在肯塔基州，我们有肯塔基心理学协会。所有州都有类似的协会，你可以联系他们。所有这些资源都是为了帮助人们获得他们需要的护理。我要再次强调的是，你确实需要受过专业培训的人员来治疗饮食失调。你想要寻找循证护理，这样人们就不会最终在不同的地方之间来回奔波，却得不到有帮助的治疗。寻求帮助是多么重要，不要因为患有饮食失调而感到羞耻。就像我说的，你绝不会因为患有癌症或其他类型的疾病而感到羞耻，对吧？
In the same way, we really want to break this stigma around having an eating disorder. They're common, they're prevalent. We can treat them, and they're nothing to be ashamed of and really want people to get help for them. Thank you. That's really great. helpful advice. I appreciate it. And I want to thank you for joining me today. Dr. Levinson, it's been very interesting. Thank you so much for having me. It was lovely being here today, and I'm excited to get some of this out there for folks to hear about. We will definitely do that.
同样，我们真的想打破这种围绕饮食失调的污名。它们很常见，很普遍。我们可以治疗它们，它们没什么可羞耻的，我们真的希望人们能为此寻求帮助。谢谢。这真是非常好的建议。我很感激。我想感谢你今天加入我的节目。Levinson博士，这非常有趣。非常感谢你的邀请。今天能来到这里真是太好了，我很高兴能把这些信息传达给人们听。我们一定会做到的。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking on Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us, at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org上，或者在Apple、Stitcher、YouTube或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，可以发送电子邮件至SpeakingofPsychology@APA.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Winerman制作。我们的声音编辑是Chris Kondyenne。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。